okay today we're going to do a little
jump scare
challenge I don't get scared I certainly
don't scream out in fear under any
circumstance you know here's the thing I
I've had one real jump scare in my life
it was actually recently and this is
true I woke up in the middle of the
night there was actually a spider
crawling against my fa crawling on my
face a spider and I didn't scream but I
did that was like I almost fell out of
bed woke up with a spider on my face so
just to give you an idea of the scale 10
is spider on my face uh to one so I'll
rate it that way I am already disturbed
by the snack selection they've put these
on the table next to me Whoppers which
are which taste disturbing um so we're
already primed here and ready to go this
first one is from The
Conjuring sounds
spooky
[Music]
is this Scene 15 minutes
long
oh come on terrifying I got honestly I
got to rate that like a two that's
that's not well no that's that's that's
a one that's the lowest level of scared
I've never been less scared in my life
than I was in that moment
okay what's the next
one what's happening here I don't have
the setup for this maybe I need to
understand the story more maybe that's
the problem
something sinister something sinister is
happening I know
that is this supposed to actually be
scary I don't even I don't know what
that was happening there maybe if I
understood better the story true crime
writer Ellison Oswalt is in a slump he
hasn't had a bestell in more than 10
years is becoming increasingly desperate
for hits when he discovers the existence
of a snuff film showing the deaths of a
family he vows to solve the mystery he
moves his own family into the victim's
home and gets to work wait a second he
sees he finds old footage of a snuff
film and so he moves his family into the
home where the snuff film happened how
did he convince his wife of that plan
that's got to cause some marital that's
got to cause a marital Rift I would
think I don't know I maybe I give that a
two I give it a to it was a little bit
creepier only because I was confused
okay this is
from The Descent a year after a severe
emotional trauma Sarah goes to North
Carolina to spend some time exploring
caves with their friends they learn they
are not
alone underground Predators inhabit the
crevices and they have a taste for human
flesh you never want to find predators
in your crevices that's for sure come
on I don't know what do you mean you
don't know there's no Breeze it could be
any one of these tunnels your
P hello please is there anybody
there
hello it's oh the scary part happened
already um I give it that three it was a
little bit the monster was pretty scary
looking like I'm not going to lie if I
was in that position I would be pretty
freaked out okay his next one's
paranormal AC activ It 2 I've heard of
this one when the Rays move into their
new Southern California home little do
they realize that the house is already
occupied
oh that was like a one that was that
that that we're now we're going in the
wrong direction what I'm trying to
figure out is they're in this
house and then things like this start to
happen and rather than moving out they
set up surveillance if it were me and
the first time that happens I'm just
moving that's it I'm not going to stick
around to see what happens next it's
frustrating okay this next okay this one
I obviously know this is it I've never
seen it uh but I have heard
that it's pretty
spooky what was the plan there is that
all this is about just setting up
that what was the plan was he just going
to stand that has he been stand the
whole time that I rate a one that was a
one all the way that was like when my
three-year-old tries to scare me that it
was like that I'm going to scare you
Daddy okay continue that's where it
lives I can't imagine anything ever
wanting to live there can we stop
talking about this I I I I can barely
breathe this is summer we're kids I can
barely bre I'm asuse SEC is this the new
it cuz this acting is terrible this is
really bad acting anyway just want to
point that out but
continue what the hell put the map
back
what the is that what the is
that turn it off turn it off yeah got
was that
[Music]
it
the acting is not good the acting is
terrible I'm sorry I I mean no offense
to those kids I know they're young kids
but you're making a movie you got to do
better than that and I don't get the
whole clown thing you know I'm not
trying to be a cont contrarian I just
don't understand the whole clowns are
scary thing I don't like they're they're
not funny either but this next one is uh
Insidious parents take drastic measures
when it seems their new home is haunted
and their komo's son is possessed by a
malevolent
entity I got to keep checking behind me
cuz you guys I could feel that someone
was awake in the
house I went into Dalton's room okay get
to the
point of course she's a woman taking
forever to tell the story there was
something in there with him well how do
you not lead with that if that's what
[Music]
happened it was standing there in the
corner
[Music]
[Applause]
I asked it who are you and it said it
was a
visitor I said what do you
want why is she having a conversation
with it I can still hear that
voice what what is here is that uh that
was like a one you want to relate to him
that there was some kind of strange
beast in his son's room last night and
you have this it takes you 10 minutes to
get I was walking up the stairs it was
cold I was hungry it was a dark night it
was like okay let's start with the
headline there was a there was a strange
figure in my son's room can you tell me
that first and we'll work backwards and
then so you you open the door and
there's this strange figure in the room
and rather than grabbing the kid and
leaving
you have a conversation with the thing
what are you here what are you doing
what do you want what's your favorite
color my first move is well first this
is why you should be armed but if you're
not armed you grab the kid and you get
out Makenna what happens next oh was a
Dream well but still my criticism stands
let's go this okay this one I know I I
remember I I saw this long time ago um
so I don't know how much luck you're
going to have on this but this is the
ring it sounds like just another urban
legend the type filled with nightmarish
images leads to a phone call for telling
the viewer's death in exactly 7 Days
newspaper reporter Rachel Keller
skeptical the story until four teenagers
all die mysteriously exactly one week
after watching Jus oh I remember this
now yeah yeah this one annoyed me too
because uh the whole premise of this
horror film is that if you watch a movie
then you'll die and of course everyone
it's like the obvious well just don't
watch it she was
close with you and Aiden
she confided in you yeah but she never
said anything nothing that would explain
what happened you could find
out it's what you do ask
questions Rachel
please I saw her
[Music]
face it wasn't really funny I don't know
why I laughed at that it's not I mean if
that happened in real life I wouldn't
think it was funny I you know I I found
this I think when I was a kid and I saw
this I was relatively scared by it so if
I'm going to rate it on me as a kid I'd
give that it was probably about a seven
but it's a one right now it's my soul
has slowly died over time all right uh
let's go to number eight is hereditary
when the matriarch of the Graham Family
passes away her daughter and grandchild
begin to unravel cryptic and
increasingly terrifying secrets about
their ancestry trying to outrun the
Sinister fate they have inherited uh
this one I haven't seen but I have heard
about it and I've heard that it's even
people I've heard from many people have
said that they're not really into horror
movies but this one dude this one is
really scary this one is I'm telling you
that's what I've
heard
that Mom up
[Music]
there I mean that's gross I don't want
to see that
[Music]
but
why would you run to the attic in a
horror
movie stop mom please stop Mom I'm sorry
okay I'm sorry Mommy please I'm beging
you of all the places to run
to what was that going on there th those
were his parents who was the naked guy
his dad who was the naked guy I'm too
confused to be scared by that once again
so I'll I'll put that a two all right
we're coming to the end of the list
mercifully this is exorcist 3 seen the
first one never saw the other two let's
see what they
got
I was looking at the popcorn I missed
that completely that might have been I
might have that might have been the 10
but I missed it cuz I was I was staring
at my popcorn so that's a one all right
our last one is relaxing car
[Music]
drive
I told you I'm not it it's um I wish you
know what I wish I had that capability
to be scared like that well uh I got to
rate that a one as well I just I I got
to be honest with my ratings you know I
think this would be a much more
entertaining uh much more entertaining
content if I was screaming like girl a
girl the whole time probably but I got
to be I got to be straightforward and
honest that I think all of those just uh
failed utterly happy
Halloween